I'm slightly shy and delighted to hear
all these beautiful words about me yes
it makes me feel good I have to say
and I hear them in the middle of Oscars
and I want to thank the four bright
beautiful and intelligent woman who
spoke and I will have a little question
are they no man in this room who love me
to speak
boom in France when we want to watch the
Oscar ceremony we have to set up our
alarm clock at 4 a.m. and we want to see
the Fashion Show the room full of
excited people not to speak about the
anxious actors and artists because it's
a fierce competition what's happening
today has nothing to do it's another
kind there is no money at stake at stake
and no competition so the governor's
gave me this a word it just I took it as
a recognition of my body of work over
the more than 60 years and it how you
see in light it gives light on me as
well as French cinema and I'm happy that
some of the leading figures of France
came to be with me and enjoyed even the
evening so I want to welcome them
Frederic brother is the president of
South Nationale du cinéma that supports
film and helps young filmmakers then we
have sir - Brianna with the president of
pinafores film supporting films and
helping young young directors and
sending the knowledge of French cinema
abroad and then we have the delegation
health of the country and festival the
famous Sharif Remo
and I'm also surrounded and protected by
my family by beautiful children Matsuda
me with actor and filmmaker Rosalie
Vedad me who recently produced with
passion energy the film faces places
that I could directed with yeah J is
here with us and then share is on the
cake two of my grandchildren are here
Valentin Vinay with a DP and after
studying at AFI and my lid yes and my
little constant enemy who still a school
here in Los Angeles
how could I forget to name and speak
about Jack to me my dear Jack was here
in 1965 nominated for the umbrellas of
Cherbourg
[Applause]
back to the topic I've been and under
loved and praised I would say because I
try to work to get the essence of cinema
finding different structure for each
film La Pointe Courte double narration
hello from five to seven real-time
vagabond 13 continuous and and
continuous traveling shots
J&B each Patris is a puzzle with missing
pieces so I also try to tell stories
with actors and non actors and went back
to the school of modesty which is
documentaries such as the Gleaners and I
but have to say I had a hard time
finding money I never met him never made
money and I'm not bankable
nevertheless if not money I got many
awards and then also honorary award such
as can pal Madhava and later because I
became older and older without losing my
desire and desire and need to work and
create I started to get Lifetime
Achievement Awards but here in a mecca
of cinema Hollywood I received the best
one the governor governor's applaud
thank you and then have to say something
else you know the other day I woke up in
the middle of night the night thinking
about my speech I got nervous started to
move my legs and my arms in the bed
moving a lot and after a while for some
reason I start to forget the weight of
my body on the mattress I felt I was
dancing tonight
I have almost the same feeling it is a
big event very serious has been
organized to celebrate the honorees we
have a room here full of cinema talent
we had two stars Angelina and Jessica
like my feminist guardian angels
and it was a big event very serious full
of meaning and weight and but I feel
that between weight and lightness I
choose I choose lightness and I feel and
I feel I'm dancing the dance of cinema
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]